quand elle était jolie ça va se faire
dans la douleur je le sais ça fait des
années qu'on est sûr je sais en à
justine où on entend dans les procès sur
les gamines l allumer son beau père
parce qu'elle se baladait en culotte à
côté de lui et parce qu'il y avait des
conflits et blablabla ans le sort qu'on
entend majoré gentiment dans les procès
j'espère que vous dirait pas le
contraire m cissé sur ces matières la
sacem peut pas laisser comme ça que ça
se passe il ya des innovations qui nous
parlons de l'inceste
écoutons leurs paroles ne commençons pas
à faire tout en un tour de parole pour
dire oui mais peut-être qu'elle ment
machin et ou peut-être qu'elle dit la
vérité et pour l'instant richard berry
de toute façon c'est prescrit donc le
débat politique composent ces deux
sessions bien ici et là et là
médiatiquement ils sont en train de le
tuer mais la mare naturelle mais la
plainte n'aboutira pas de toute façon
égale comment y aura enquête
effectivement et c'est un classement
sans suite mais c'est vous dire il ya
des plaintes après il porte plainte
je vais vous dire qu'ici on est pas les
avocats de richard berry mais pas du
tout mais vraiment voilà on va courir
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas du tout les
avocats de richard berry on est juste
voilà et je vous le dis fatima c'est que
voilà deux mois cancon polanski était
aux césar on a été les premiers
d'ailleurs c'est le même bruit que nous
on a été les premiers à dire que c'était
inadmissible et moi des lainages lui
donne cent fois raison
voilà d'adeptes d'être partie des césar
je pense qu'elle a très bien fait mais
elle a pris la bonne décision
j'ai aujourd'hui ce qui nous on attend
on attend que gestionnaire son cours de
son binôme on avocat la présence à dire
celui qui ne le fait pas j'aurais adoré
c'est le seul ministère la justice qui a
comme nom une vertu la justice
effectivement envie de croire la justice
de son pays
je peux vous assurer que je suis entré
dans le militantisme en 2009
à chaque fois que j'y crois encore je
vais en procès je me dis moi si ça va
bien se passer
c'est ce passé cette fois-ci c'est après
mis tout mais c'est pas vrai et jusqu'à
il ya quelques ya quelques semaines le
garde des sceaux nous faisait mentir sur
notre propre chiffre maintenant il les
reconnaît reconnaissons-le expertise de
militantes féministes qui nous sommes
pas sur des positions idéologiques mais
qui avant une expertise de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui le viol la
pédocriminalité les uns c'est ce sont
des crimes massivement
puni en ce moment c'est la vérité